في الحقيقه يعني مدينه غازي عنتاب بدات
تستعيد شيئا من الحياه فيها وبدات المحاله
التجاريه والاسواق تفتح من جديد كل ذلك في
جهود تسعه من خلالها السلطات الرسميه
لاعاده الحياه وطمانه الناس وتحديد
المتضررين ونقلهم الى مساكن جديده في غاز
عنتاب بدات قبل يوم او يومين تقريبا عمليه
بناء لمساكن مؤقته خصوصا في المناطق
الاكثر تضررا وهي مدينتي
الاصلاحيه ونورداغ حاليا هناك يتم عمليه
بناء البيوت متنقله ستوي اكثر من 30 الف
بالاضافه الى جهود مستمره من قبل السلطات
في اعاده الكهرباء والغاز والمياه على
جميع المناطق في ولايه غازي عنتاب شاهدنا
بالرغم من ان الهزات الارضيه التي ما زالت
مستمره والتي شعرنا بها طوال ليله امس الا
ان هنالك حركه لعوده الناس الى منازلهم
وترك الحدائق الاشخاص الذين لم يتمكنوا من
الحصول على خيام لان هنالك اعداد كبيره
نتحدث عن عن مدينه كبيره اما الاشخاص
الذين حصلوا على الخيام بالفعل والتي يعني
بلغ عدده اكثر من عشرين الف خيمه فهم لا
يزالون في هذه الخيام الجهود تتركز على
جميع الاصعده متعلقه بتوزيع الطعام
والغذاء بالاضافه الى عمليات
التعقيم ورش المبيدات تخوفه من الاوبئه
بالاضافه الى عمليات حتى يعني التعليم
والدعم النفسي نحن الان في هذه الحديقه
هنا بالقرب منها يوجد يعني
هنا هذه خيمه صنعتها او وضعتها السلطات
المحليه للدعم النفسي للاطفال
تجري فيها عمليه دعم الاطفال الذين هم
يعني متاثرين بسبب هذا الزلزال وكان قد
تحدث ضيفنا قبل قليل عن هذا الامر وقضيه
التغير النفسي والاطفال لعلهم اكثر
الاشخاص او اكثر الناس الذين هم تاثرا هنا
نشاهد عمليه تعليم بالاضافه الى بعض
عمليات الترفيه التي تقوم بها هذه
تقوم بها السلطات هنا بالتعاون مع منظمات
اهليه
بالقرب من هذا المخيم وهذا يجري وينطبق
على اكثر المخيمات التي يعني وضعت في هذه
المنطقه نشاهد هنا يعني في ظل سطوع الشمس
والتي كسرت قليلا من
البروده التي عاشتها غازي عنتاب خلال
الايام الماضيه فيعني هنا يحاولون من خلال
هذه الامور ان يعني يقدموا دعما نفسيا
للاطفال وترفيهيا حتى
يغيروا من نفسيتهم بعد الايام الصعبه التي
عاشوها في درجات حراره منخفضه وفي الخيام
ومنهم من كان في السيارات ومنهم في مراكز
الايواء ومن هم الجلسه في المساجد كان
هناك اكثر من 100 الف شخص في مساجد غازي
عنتاب اكثر من 125 الف شخص في المدارس
بالاضافه الى الاشخاص الذين هربوا خرج
غازي عنتاب والذين ذهبوا الى
الطرقات يعني خارج طرقات رئيسيه التي خارج
مدينه ولايه غازي عنتاب حتى
الذين ذهبوا الى الولايات الاخرى باستخدام
سياراتهم كل هذه هي ضمن جهود تحاول من
خلال سلطات الرسميه اليوم اعاده المدينه
واعاده الحياه الى هذه المدينه
بعد اكثر من عشره ايام على هذه الكارثه
وهذا ايضا ينطبق على عمليه
تقييم الابنيه في ولايه غازي عنتاب وتحديد
الاضرار ومن ثم دفع الناس الذين يعني
يجدون ابنيتهم غير متضرره بالعوده الى هذه
الابنيه بالرغم ان شاهدنا كثير من الاشخاص
يقومون باخلاء ابنيه على يبدو انها من
الامنيه التي سيتم هدمها وان السلطات قيمه
وضعها بوضع سيء وخطر شكرا جزيلا لك منتصر
ابو نبوت من غازي عنت